[Aplausos]
[Música]
delaware es la capital comercial de eeuu
cuando se habla de negocios en este país
de la web es para el mundo empresarial
lo mismo que hollywood es para la
industria del cine la meca del business
[Música]
estoy seguro de que antes de ver este
vídeo podríais pensar que el epicentro
económico de eeuu podía estar qué sé yo
en nueva york con los lobos de wall
street o en california con nuestros
amigos de silicon valley pero no mis
queridos amigos de visual político
gigantes estadounidenses como amazon
cocacola facebook word
general electric google todas estas
empresas tienen su dirección comercial
en wilmington la ciudad más grande del
estado de delaware y ya se lo que
estaréis pensando muchos madre mía con
todas estas compañías wilmington tiene
que tener un skyline impresionante y
lleno de rascacielos verdad pues no de
hecho si entráis un poco más al detalle
podréis ver como la dirección de estas
empresas se va repitiendo siempre es en
1209 de north orange street en
wilmington y entonces uno ya se imagina
vale quizás wilmington no tiene un
skyline impresionante pero vamos que en
1209 de north o rage street no es un
rascacielos cualquiera es el rascacielos
la madre de todos los rascacielos y en
esos momentos es cuando nos mete
en google streetview y que nos
encontramos pues que la sede de más de
300.000 empresas de eeuu es esto
pues sí que tienen que estar apretadito
spray dentro vamos que tiene que ser
como el camarote de los hermanos marx el
caso es que si pensáis que aquí hay gato
encerrado estáis en lo cierto los que
estéis ya un poco metidos en el mundo de
los negocios seguro que ya sabéis lo que
sucede en delaware porque si de algo
tiene fama este estado es de ser un
paraíso fiscal pero en este vídeo vais a
ver que delaware es algo más que un
paraíso fiscal de la web es un símbolo
de toda una forma de hacer negocios una
forma de hacer negocios que tal vez
tengan los días contados
así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es por qué delaware es la capital
comercial de eeuu y no los auténticos
epicentros económicos del país porque
decimos que delaware es un paraíso
fiscal si en realidad soportan impuestos
federales como cualquier otro estado de
norteamérica hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
e
más empresas que personas eeuu es el
cuarto país más grande y tercero más
poblado después de china e india ahora
bien dentro de eeuu qué rol desempeña
delaware pues si no eres de todos unidos
lo más probable es que no hayas oído
hablar de este estado en tu vida y no me
extraña al fin y al cabo es el segundo
estado más pequeño de eeuu para que os
hagáis una idea la isla de puerto rico
es más grande que delaware de una punta
a otra del estado hay menos de 200
kilómetros y en cuanto a población
apenas roza el millón de habitantes así
que en principio delaware jugaría el
mismo papel que chipre dentro de la
unión europea
e
así que os preguntaréis cómo es posible
que delaware haya conseguido llevarse
empresas en el territorio con el mismo
éxito con el que neymar se lleva a top
models a su fiesta de cumpleaños para
entenderlo hay que tener una cosa muy
clara
eeuu es un país federal lo forman 50
estados y entre ellos tienen leyes muy
diferentes por ejemplo si vives en
vermont y te quieres divorciar todo el
mundo te aconseja que te vayas al vecino
new hampshire porque os lo explico
imaginad que vivo en montpellier la
capital de vermont y estoy casado con un
haber montesa nos queremos divorciar
pues bien lo primero que nos van a decir
los abogados es que conseguir el
divorcio en vermont nos va a llevar como
mínimo más de un año sin embargo si
cogemos el coche y nos vamos doscientos
kilómetros al sureste a concord la
capital de new hampshire ahí nos podemos
divorciar en tan solo un día no es
maravilloso vamos si algún día me caso y
me quiero divorciarme iré a new
hampshire y os prometo un vídeo desde la
cabaña de walter white pero mientras
tanto os voy a contar lo de delaware
todo empezó a finales del siglo 19 hasta
entonces lo normal
era que una empresa registrará su sede
comercial en el estado en el que
desarrollaba su actividad sin embargo
nueva jersey fue el primer estado en
darse cuenta del business que podía
hacer
en nueva yersey pensaron si atraemos
aquí empresas que operan en otros
estados pagarán aquí algunos impuestos
que hasta ahora están pagando en otros
estados para ello aprobaron una serie de
ventajas fiscales y podéis imaginar lo
que dijeron todos los empresarios nos
vamos todos la nueva jersey hacia el año
1909 ayer se había logrado tal éxito que
otros estados con problemas para cuadrar
sus cuentas copiaron su legislación
de esta forma territorios como arizona o
maine intentaron convertirse en los
nuevos paraísos empresariales algunos
estados prometieron tarifas más bajas
otros regulaciones más suaves pero la
ley de corporaciones de delaware fue la
que logró el mayor éxito
los que no veían bien esta competencia
entre estados denominaron esta pugna
como una rise to the back una carrera
hacia el abismo
sus ideas quedaron tanto que los estados
fueron retirando todas esas ventajas que
ofrecían a las empresas también nueva
yersey pese a que habían sido los
pioneros todos ellos dieron un paso
atrás
- delaware que desde 1913 se convirtió
como he dicho al principio en la meca
del business actualmente en delaware
están registradas más de un millón de
empresas mientras que la población
alcanza las 950 mil personas la clave de
su éxito ha sido mantener un clima ideal
para hacer negocios un marco legal que
ofrece la suficiente confianza a
accionistas empresarios e inversores en
delaware pegas una patada y te salen
cinco abogados seis economistas y siete
contables todo gira en torno a los
servicios corporativos
[Música]
delaware se ha ganado una fama un
prestigio que hace que la llamen por
estas tierras the franchise es decir la
franquicia lo que para muchos es un
paraíso fiscal para delaware es su forma
de ganarse la vida porque al final los
impuestos y las tarifas judiciales
pagadas con las entidades comerciales
representan casi un tercio de los
ingresos del estado un siglo después dan
hour se sigue manteniendo en la cresta
de la ola pero y como lo consigue pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la franquicia si eres un abogado en eeuu
estoy seguro de que te conoces de
memoria las leyes de dos estados las del
lugar en el que trabajas y las de
delaware
y si muchos podréis criticar que un
estado decida ser un paraíso fiscal pero
pensando desde este otro punto de vista
gracias a que eeuu es un país federal
cada estado puede especializarse en
cosas distintas para poder competir
arizona por ejemplo tiene el gran cañón
que atrae turismo main se ha
desarrollado en la industria papelera o
pesquera sin embargo de la web es que no
tienen nada el auto se tiene que
especializar pues bien se han
especializado en atraer empresas de esta
forma en lugar de que toda la riqueza
vaya a tres o cuatro puntos bien
localizados y al estado puede encontrar
un área en el que especializarse y
atraer distintos tipos de negocios
gracias a que eeuu es un país federal
cada estado puede especializarse en
cosas distintas para poder competir
arizona por ejemplo tiene el gran cañón
que atrae turismo main se ha
desarrollado en la industria papelera o
pesquera sin embargo de la web es que no
tienen nada en algo se tienen que
especializar pues bien se han
especializado en atraer empresas
[Música]
pero ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando a estas alturas vale fonseca
así que son un paraíso fiscal pero cuál
es exactamente esa ventaja fiscal que
ofrece delaware pues bien en eeuu las
compañías pagan impuestos federales y
locales el impuesto de sociedades-
federal es del 21% y afecta a delaware
como a los demás estados pero después
hay un impuesto estatal que puede ser de
hasta el 9% el truco está en que hay un
tipo de sociedad empresarial las
denominadas llc es que en delaware están
exentas de ese 9% estatal si no
desarrollan su actividad dentro del
estado
el 64% de las empresas del fortune 500
están registradas en delaware una buena
estrategia fiscal puede reducir los
impuestos entre un 10 y un 40% los que
saben del asunto calculan que otros
estados dejan de recaudar entre 6.500 y
9 mil 500 millones de dólares por lo que
llaman desde la web lupus o la
escapatoria de delaware os voy a poner
un ejemplo para que lo entendáis mejor
os acordáis de esto y serás esas tiendas
de juguetes cuyo modelo de negocio
arruinó 10 veces cuando creó amazon pues
bien toysrus tenían una mascota la
jirafa geoffrey toysrus creó una
sociedad en delaware que se llamaba
geoffrey llc a la que le transfirió los
derechos de imagen de la jirafa jong
en este modo todos los toysrus del mundo
enviaban buena parte de sus ingresos a
esa filial de delaware como pago por
utilizar en sus tiendas como reclamo
comercial a la jirafa geoffrey así es
como conseguían dos cosas una todo el
dinero enviado de la web quedaba exento
del impuesto estatal de sociedades y dos
anotarlo como un gasto en las cuentas
las tiendas de toysrus disminuían
artificialmente su beneficio y así los
agentes tributarios no tenían donde
rascar ni un centavo como precio por ver
en de la web y beneficiarse de estas
ventajas el estado cobra sus sociedades
el franchise tax o impuestos de
franquicia
[Música]
y qué consiste este impuesto pues se
trata de una especie de pago anual en
función del tamaño de la empresa está
franchise tax puede ir desde los 175 y
los 250 dólares que pagan las empresas
más pequeñas hasta los 200 mil dólares
que pagan como máximo las grandes
corporaciones y ya sé lo que me vais a
decir muchos bueno aún así siguen
pagando un 21% de impuestos de
sociedades no está nada mal pues si
tenéis razón en realidad lo que más les
gusta a las empresas que trabajan el de
la web no son tanto los impuestos como
el hecho de que en sus tribunales no hay
sorpresas en este caso juega un papel
decisivo lo que llaman la court of
sunseri su tribunal especial para
abordar temas de negocios eso y el
tribunal supremo de delaware son jueces
experimentados que trabajan con una
legislación y una jurisprudencia muy
favorable para los negocios
y ojo cuando hablamos de negocios no
penséis solamente en el ceo de la
empresa sino que también hablamos de los
accionistas que en muchos casos pueden
tener intereses contrapuestos a la
directiva de la empresa a qué me refiero
exactamente pues por ejemplo a que sus
jueces son poco amigos de las demandas
de los accionistas es decir cuando un
accionista de una compañía no está de
acuerdo con la gestión del consejo de
administración una de sus opciones es
acudir a la justicia para defender sus
intereses pero será mejor que os lo
explique con un ejemplo reciente
[Música]
el supremo de delaware rechaza reabrir
la causa de un accionista contra uber os
cuento rápidamente de qué va esto tenéis
la junta directiva de uber decidió en el
año 2016 invertir casi 700 millones de
dólares en una startup de un antiguo
ingeniero de google
el objetivo era desarrollar el famoso 2
autónomo parece que ni a través cala ni
cofundador de uber ni a nadie del
consejo de administración se les pasó
por la cabeza que aquello no le haría
mucha gracia a google y efectivamente no
tardó en caerle es una demanda de google
por robo de propiedad intelectual sobre
la tecnología de one
[Música]
en resumen la broma le costó a uber 245
millones de dólares y por este motivo un
accionista decidió demandar a la
directiva de uber por su gestión y
sabéis que le ha dicho el supremo de
delaware pues que podría reclamar si se
hubiera quejado en un primer momento a
la directiva de uber cuando decidió
invertir en la startup y no ahora que se
sabe que la inversión había sido una
ruina tiene sentido verdad ahora tampoco
quiero que penséis que siempre se falla
a favor de las empresas con más bien de
sus consejos directivos facebook bien lo
sabe con el caso de cambridge analítica
[Música]
en facebook pierde la batalla judicial
para mantener bajo secreto su registro
sobre brechas de seguridad internas otro
caso muy interesante para las empresas
es el de las sopas la legislación de
delaware ha cambiado porque antes
ofrecía demasiados incentivos para que
los accionistas rechazarán vender sus
acciones y presentarán demandas silao
para finalmente tenía éxito siempre
salían ganando si tenían razón con que
el precio oferta de la opa era bajo la
compañía compradora tenía que pagarles
el precio marcado por el juez si no
tenían razón seguían recibiendo el
precio marcado por la opa y cobraban un
interés del 5% sobre el dinero retenido
mientras duraba el proceso judicial
[Música]
sin embargo con los últimos cambios
legislativos se ha acabado lo de cobrar
intereses y si el accionista no tiene
razón con su demanda lo más probable es
que reciba un precio inferior al marcado
por la opa así que presentar demandas ha
dejado de ser un negocio seguro para las
accionistas
y ahora presenta sus riesgos en otras
palabras que como podéis ver hay muchos
detalles que van mucho más allá de los
impuestos bajos si tenéis una gran
empresa con muchísimos accionistas y
cotizadas en la bolsa os compensa estar
en el estado de delaware pero esperad un
momento porque no todo es tan bonito
cuál es el mayor peligro que tienen este
tipo de prácticas pues atentos
el capitalismo fantasma registra una
empresa ante la web es muy fácil te
piden menos datos que para solicitar el
carnet en la biblioteca municipal por
eso está el secreto corporativo que
también es una de las causas que explica
el éxito de delaware te contrata a
cualquier abogado para que se encargue
del papeleo y no hay ninguna obligación
de dejar constancia y quienes son los
verdaderos propietarios de la empresa
dicho de otra forma de la web es el
lugar ideal para operar con empresas
fantasma esta falta de transparencia
podría equipararse al secreto bancario
que tenían hace años en países como
liechtenstein o sitios
el secreto bancario nació con buenas
intenciones era la forma de poner
cortafuegos para proteger algunas
fortunas de la sed de fondos que
generaban las guerras que devastaron el
mundo en la primera mitad del siglo 20
eso y proteger los ahorros de los judíos
que estaban perseguidos por los nazis el
problema es que cuando permites que
existe el secreto corporativo estás
abriendo una puerta por la que intentan
colarse todos los interesados en que no
salgan a la luz sus oscuras actividades
os hablo de políticos corruptos
terroristas traficantes de armas y
narcotraficantes que ocultan con estas
empresas fantasmas su identidad mientras
buscan la forma de lavar dinero
tras décadas de fracaso en la lucha
contra el crimen organizado parece que
hace cuatro años empezaron a cambiar las
cosas
reino unido se comprometió a tener
registros públicos sobre la propiedad
real de las empresas y desde entonces
algunos de los centros offshore más
grandes del mundo están aumentando la
transparencia corporativa sobre la
propiedad con compromisos para el año
[Música]
jones agency e isla de mann establecerán
registros públicos de propietarios de
empresas y por supuesto en eeuu también
se han puesto manos a la obra no es el
primer intento desde instancias
federales para acabar con el secreto
corporativo de estados como delaware
pero si es el primero que avanza con
éxito en el concreto se trata de la ley
de transparencia corporativa que el
senado de eeuu va a empezar a examinar
durante este año que empieza el año 2020
el objetivo es que las compañías estén
obligadas a revelar sus beneficios
reales a una agencia federal la red de
cumplimiento de delitos financieros y
que mantengan actualizada su información
de propiedad esta medida permitiría
levantar el secreto empresarial de
estados como delaware o nevada y por
supuesto atajar el blanqueo de capitales
la buena noticia es que parece que ambos
partidos tanto los demócratas como los
republicanos ya están concienciados de
que el secreto corporativo perjudica
seriamente la lucha contra los delitos
financieros la mala noticia es que hasta
ahora parece que ambos partidos sólo
conocían sus ventajas lo sabían los
clinton que cobraban más de doscientos
mil dólares por cada una de sus
conferencias
no sabéis cómo canalizaban estos
ingresos exacto a través de sociedades
llc registradas en delaware pero atentos
porque los escritos no son los únicos él
también
sabéis que hacemos muchos negocios dónde
la web es bueno porque eso significa
impuestos y todas esas cosas así que
pregunté cuántas entidades tenemos
registradas en delaware en plan empresas
y así entonces pensé que dirían quizás
dos o tres verdad 378 dije que así que
tenemos 378 entidades registradas en el
estado de delaware
esto significa que os pagó mucho dinero
amigos no me parece del todo mal está
bien desde luego si se aprueba la ley de
transparencia corporativa estaríamos
ante el cambio regulatorio más
importante en este ámbito en los últimos
50 años estaremos atentos a ver lo que
sucede pero ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros qué os parece de la web estáis
pensando en registrar una empresa allí o
creéis que es su competitividad fiscal
perjudica al conjunto de eeuu
más cuántos de vosotros tenéis una
jirafa geoffrey enviarme una por favor
que vale millones gracias por adelantado
y podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios mientras tanto no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribirse a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]